اقف الان في ساحه الحريه في وسط العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن دي سي حيث هذه المظاهره
الاحتجاجيه على الحرب في غزه هذه المظاهره
التي يحتشد فيها الالاف وتعد واحده من
اكبر واقوى المظاهرات التي تشهدها العاصمه
الامريكيه احتجاجا على الحرب في غزه هذه
المظاهره يشارك فيها الكثير من الفعاليات
السياسيه والشعبيه عدد من اعضاء الكونجرس
الامريكي وكذلك عدد من ممثلي وزعماء
الجاليات الاسلاميه وكذلك عدد من رموز
اليهود في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الذين يصفون اسرائيل بالصهيونيه ويقولون
انها تزرع الكراهيه وتسفك الدماء في
المنطقه وانها تمارس الاباده الجماعيه
والتطهير العرقي هذه المظاهره يفترض ان
تتحول بعد ذلك الى مسيره الى البيت الابيض
الامريكي لممارسه المزيد من الضغوط على
الاداره الامريكيه وعلى الرئيس الامريكي
جو با
لوقف الحرب فورا ووقف تزويد اسرائيل
بالاسلحه ووقف دعم اسرائيل كما يقولون هذه
المظاهره سبقها مؤتمرات صحفيه لعدد من اسر
الفلسطينيين الامريكيين الفلسطينيين في
غزه والذين قتلت اعداد كبيره من اسرهم حيث
تحدثوا عن الانتهاكات الجسيمه للحرب في
غزه كذلك كانت هناك كلمه مسجله للزميل
وائل الدح مراسل شبكه الجزيره في غزه
ومدير مكتبها في غزه يتحدث ايضا عما
يعانيه الصحفيون وكذلك الاعمال القتلى
التي استهدفت المجتمع الصحفي في غزه
واستهدفت اسكات كل الاصوات التي تنقل
الحقيقه من قطاع غزه هذه المظاهره مستمره
ورغم بروده الطقس وستتوجه الى البيت
الابيض بعد ذلك كما ذكرنا لممارسه المزيد
من الضغوط على الاداره الامريكيه عبد
الفتاح فايد الجزيره
واشنطن